The Joe Rogan experience.
It seems like a lot of people
would want to listen to you though.
I would imagine if I was in camp with
a guy like you and I saw the kind of
cardio that you have for a big guy and
the amount of effort that you put in.
I would imagine there's other
dudes that are following you now.
No, I my teammates. Yeah. They know
like I'm one of the guys, my bike,
a brother to me, his car over sin.
You're saying he stepped down,
he stepped up on the glorified.
That's something we talked
about when he was an amateur.
I've been working with amateur and I told
his coach stand like this kid is good.
He's correct stuff.
He'd go pro.
He'd been UFC in no time telling
you cause he was, I watched him, me,
him and Chris Weidman.
He came in with us when I was hoping
why more the Rocco fight and I've,
I'm not sure if he was an amateur or pro
yet, but he was hanging his, you just,
you and her hustling. He didn't
have that, but striking wise,
he was giving us problems. It was like,
this is, this kid is good. He's like, oh,
he's a glory kickboxing. Ah, that
makes sense. He kicks hard like,
I haven't seen them put many people were
asleep with his head kicked in practice
like Yo pull. He's like, Bro, that
wasn't your heart. Like what'd you mean?
It wasn't high.
Like I just flicked it up there,
but he's just so explosive and
athletic. He hit me with a knee. What?
Last Saturday my chest still hurt.
It was like I shot and he caught me coming
down and shot and I was like, Oh shit.
But I was in deep, but he just so
quick. It's just, but like he's one,
he hits me up all the time.
When you come to camp like, oh,
he has died down because of
Bo and Clint out of the pie,
but to come like the work and
stuff. Should we keep doing
this? Should we do this?
I'm going to run today,
so when I want to work on my Jujitsu,
what should I do this? Should I just
drill? Should we go hard? Should I go?
Who trained? Sometimes the
performance institute in Vegas,
every time we get to camp, me and him, we
got to think if one of us getting camp,
we already know I'm a contact
him. You gotta fight when
we go into Vegas. So I go,
we go out there for a week or two weeks.
Me, him and Rex Harris, he was in the Pff,
we call each other. The bass pro's only
three dudes that you'll see in Jersey.
We didn't traveled around.
We'd been to Vegas,
we've been to Arizona or
wherever we go and we go hard.
And that's why we call it a basketball.
There's no,
oh we're going light today bro. Don't hit
me every time. It's like, are we ready?
You Ready? Rex actually texted me
was gonna take Mo. He was like, yeah,
I'll be there tomorrow cause I'm flying
here and I'll get back in time for
training. So Bass Bros meet up and
we'd go at it. That's it. Are you,
are you always far and hard or do
you spark? We got certain days,
like if we don't want to spoil heart,
we know not to go with each other because
it's kind of like if one week I get
the best of wrecks.
Like there's been times like I had Carl
for we're OSP cause he south Pauling
super good.
So I won't recall three rounds heart.
So it was his main focus was take down,
no let them up.
So I take him down and beat him
on the ground, feet on the ground,
taking him down and beat him on the ground
cause he didn't have wrestling at the
time. And then he would go
with like somebody else.
Like I need one more around and
he'd be mad a lot. I know that,
but that's why I'm not going home
on the fourth, the fourth round,
cause he's mad and he'd go out
there with somebody else and just,
you just eat them up. It's like,
I'm sorry, I have to apologize.
The other guy like I'm sorry for
beating him up because the hostility.
So we go hard,
but there's times we pull other guys and
like I'm gonna call this amateur guy in
pretty good amateur or
a low level pro pro.
Some guys at 80 Alvarez knows
whenever I got this kid,
he's pro two oh five he's the beginning
or whatever you want to work with him.
That's the guy. Bring him up to the,
I'm going to do a technical move day.
Kinda like wall work,
drilling. We sparring.
We have Hagar on just in case
cause accidents happened,
but nothing has strong with
intention to hurt anybody.